pique sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous
présente c'est vous la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la canebière le vieux port notre dame de
la garde
les indispensables cartes postales de
marseille pourtant c'est dans une autre
ambiance moins célèbres mais aussi
typiquement marseillaise que nous avons
rendez vous ce samedi à quelques
centaines de mètres de la cité
félix-pyat dans le 3e arrondissement
certains marseillais se sont réunis pour
un magelis un mot arabe qui signifie
assembler tous les habitants de la cité
phocéenne présent cet après midi sont
originaires du même pays la plupart sont
même nés dans cet archipel du sud de
l'océan indien les comores et le majilis
auxquels ils sont venus participer à un
objectif
il s'agit de récolter des fonds pour
créer dans la ville une maison des
comores un lieu qui fera enfin découvrir
cette communauté son histoire sa musique
ses cultures
[Musique]
à la tête de cet événement dit lesley on
ne me voit pas assez ne vous connais pas
assez
est ce que nous voulons c'est
transmettre les traditions à nos enfants
transmettre notre culture qui est forte
notre identité qui est fort mais tout ça
dans les valeurs de la république
ces magies leasecom en rien est un
événement typiques de la ville
c'est un fait souvent méconnus du plus
grand nombre mais un marseillais sur dix
seraient d'origine comorienne
en d'autres termes les comoriens
représentera 10% du million d'habitants
que compte la deuxième ville de france
[Musique]
et pourtant ils sont presque invisibles
il faut dire que les comoriens vivent
discrètement le plus souvent au sein
d'une communauté où les valeurs
traditionnelles prix sur
l'individualisme à l'occidentale il
existe même une valeur suprême le
chéreau l'honneur du groupe que chacun
doit respecter au risque de devenir un
pari pourtant les plus jeunes prennent
de la distance avec cette culture
parfois en contradiction avec la société
française
et vous la france vous invite à plonger
dans cette culture comorienne de
marseille avec les acteurs qui la vivent
au quotidien
[Musique]
ma lisa said so i ly 34 ans a grandi
dans la cité du plan d'aou un lieu
symbole des quartiers nord en quelques
années la jeune femme est devenue une
figure de la communauté comorienne de
marseille et 6 r
la fameuse place vexe
là où se retrouvent d'ailleurs toute la
communauté
en tout cas les hommes voilà c'est un
peu la place publique
là haut on apprend tout ce qui se passe
on n'a même pas besoin d'allumer la télé
ou de chercher les infos il suffit de
venir à la place des ex
marseille pour moi c'est une mosaïque à
ces 1/4 faut c'est un lieu de rencontre
c'est une terre d'accueil c'est ce qui
fait qu'on se sent bien ici on se sent
chez soi malizé a choisi de s'engager en
politique
elle a rejoint la majorité municipale
aux côtés de jean claude gaudin la jeune
femme
énarque est vite monté dans la
hiérarchie conseillère municipale elle
est en charge des affaires européennes
et de l'information digital je suis
femme noire confession musulmane
en fait ce délit de la république
d'origine comorienne enfin bref tout est
à nous en poupe et qui finalement me
définisse un discours très républicain
pour résumer un engagement m'a lisa
pourrait faire figure de modèle de la
méritocratie à la française ce pourrait
être un autre cliché même à lisa
revendique son appartenance à la double
culture franco comorienne et au sein des
décideurs de la cité phocéenne
elle reste une exception sur les huit
mairies d'arrondissement ils ne sont que
deux conseillers municipaux d'origine
comorienne
mais cette singularité devient un outil
pour travailler au quotidien as à la
jeune femme se met au service des
différentes composantes qui constituent
la population de la ville entre affalé
au ce matin par exemple ma lisa reçoit
dans son bureau
cette jeune femme d'origine sénégalaise
et même si elle n'est pas vraiment en
charge du dossier
elle va l'aider à constituer sa demande
dette sociale parce qu'en fait moi ce
qu'il aurait fallu l'attestation
l'attestation il fallait rappeler et je
veux leur dire que je souhaitais voir ce
qu'on peut faire mon niveau des
municipalités pour aider ce travail au
plus près de la vie de ses administrés
est devenu une habitude
souvent mal isa est obligé de leur
rappeler qu'elle est une élue de la
république élu par les marseillais pour
les marseillais
et pas seulement pour les comoriens ou
les africains mais eux la considèrent
comme une représentante de leur
communauté
toutes les communautés de manière
générale elle
trouve une certaine facilité à me saisir
mois plus tôt que mes collègues parce
qu'ils se disent que finalement on est
comme moi davantage ressemblé donc
davantage se comprendre elle la parole
est plus libre et donc ils préfèrent
finalement s'adresser à moi ya pas de
ses plus demain je rappelle madame
newman a alors demandé pour
l'attestation s'il est possible de la
produire et je me raccompagnait cet
engagement de ma lisa c'est un peu la
continuité d'une histoire familiale au
service de la france
une histoire qui est largement partagé
par de nombreuses familles venues des
comores il retrouvait ça en fait c'est
l'une des médailles comme mon grand-père
à une france libre il a eu bien
aussi la légion d'honneur la résille
médaille de la résistance comme ça que
toute l'histoire a commencé en france en
tout cas pour ma famille cet aïeul
engagé dans l'armée française durant la
seconde guerre mondiale s'établit
définitivement à marseille en 1967
mon grand-père à 14 ans étaient à
madagascar et c'était la période où on
allait chercher en outre-mer des jeunes
pour venir combattre c'est un peu
finalement le résumé de l'histoire de
l'immigration comorienne en france au
début des années 80 la grand mère de ma
liseur rejoint son époux l'histoire de
sa grand-mère aussi est typique des
femmes venus des anciennes colonies
d'abord femme de ménage dans les cinémas
elle a continué comme cuisinière dans
les restaurants toutes ces familles qui
arrivait à marseille s'établissait dans
les quartiers nord c'était pas dans les
quartiers huppés qu'on connaît ici à
marseille
souvent trop sollicité par sa vie
politique ma lisa arrive à s'aménager
quelques précieux moments avec ses
enfants
ces instants de vie de famille sont
l'occasion de transmettre à son tour la
culture dans laquelle elle est bercée
depuis sa naissance
c'est maintenant combien la nana trois
mois je reprends mes enfants qui sont
aussi bien comment les 100 français qui
peuvent se sentir aussi bien les uns
m'ont dit qu'à paris et que de toujours
refusé ce qui leur running leur
nationalité
voilà donc qu'ils apprennent à chanter
la marseillaise
on va prendre et apprennent à chanter
l'hymne national comorien
qu'at il à elle adore les gars très
rouge et c'était quoi le bientôt tu
m'avais dit de faire la dernière fois le
gâteau avec plein de couleurs quand ça
s'appelle de moi laquelle elle préfère
qu'on fasse le gâteau luigi couleurs
mais bon ça prend tout un après midi
même dans sa cuisine malizé a besoin
d'avoir des saveurs de son archipel
cardamone poivre clous de girofle des
condiments introuvables dans le commerce
de marseille
la margarine que j'utilise pour faire le
pilat au on fait venir des commandes
toutes les épices qui sont là c'est un
peu le graal
oui six mois en l'économie redécouvre
aussi parce que ben sa cinquième parfum
dès qu'on les ouvre
dans ce sens le parfum des commandes
la cuisine c'est aussi le lieu
privilégié de l'expression de la double
culture de la famille qui célèbre
indifféremment les fêtes musulmanes et
chrétiennes mais maintenant on se
retrouve tout pour le genre de live on
se retrouve tout est bel et bien disent
oui mais les comoriennes
elle fait des traditions noël je suis
aussi françaises
au travers de cette éducation
multiculturelle ma lisa espère comme de
nombreux comoriens transmettre et faire
rayonner sa culture ici à marseille un
long chemin pour promouvoir une
communauté qui jusqu'à présent s'est
voulu si discrète mais les temps
changent
80 14e foire internationale de marseille
comme chaque année des artistes des
artisans des commerçants du monde entier
se retrouvent au parc chanot pour mettre
en avant des produits de leur pays
mais il a fallu attendre cette édition
2010 8 pour que les comores soit
représentée par un pavillon etc manisa
qui a impulsé cette initiative c'est
quand même un peu dommage que cette
première communauté à marseille ne soit
pas présente à la fois presque la force
et aussi l'habitude
[Musique]
moi
au parc chanot nous croisons bananière
saadi un journaliste comoriens autre
figure de la communauté marseillaise est
lui aussi est très fier que sa culture
sorte enfants du ghetto des quartiers
nord pour s'étaler sur les stands dans
ce rôle international
c'est aussi le faire découvrir les
comores au nom comment bien de venir
découvrir
aux us et coutumes n'auront pas nos
habits donc ses moyens et ses meilleurs
moyens qu'une foire internationale pour
être parmi les quelques jours plus tard
nous retrouvons bell mears a dit sur le
vieux port n'est décor de carte postale
et l'endroit que ce marathonien a choisi
pour terrain d'entraînement à 41 ans
ben à venir collectionne les casquettes
journaliste cameraman pour les médias de
son pays mais aussi manager de l'équipe
de football des comores et entrepreneur
marseillais arrivé à l'âge de 7 ans dans
la cité phocéenne et la grandit sur les
bords de la méditerranée
il se sent appartenir à la deuxième
génération des comoriens de provence
non nous sommes la génération où nous
sommes ici nous avons fait nos études
ici nous sommes mariés ici notre vie est
ici et donc on est une transition avec
la génération qui vient qui elle doit à
la fois à se raccrocher à un pays qu'il
ne connaît pas et nous qui sommes au
milieu qui devront transmettre on va
dire celle enfin les rêves et mes
transmettent les rêves d'un retour au
pays et développer la vie ici à
marseille
cette double injonction qui pourrait
sembler paradoxal benali on a fait un
engagement très concret il s'investit
ici en france développe une entreprise
d'informatique et promeut grâce à son
métier grâce au sport grâce aux médias
les liens économiques et culturels entre
la france et l'archipel
c'est vrai que ça commence à filmer ici
voilà c'est mon bordel c'est un fourre
tout mais je me retrouve pendant près de
dix ans avec une poignée d'amis d'amis
relance comme armagh un journal
marseillais dédié à la communauté
donc comment max le premier premier
magasin comoriens compris entre les deux
aussi bien par rapport à la dispora
qu'aux comores qui était un mensuel
c'était un peu de tout par exemple la
quantité le rôle statut la place de la
femme pendant que moyenne moi je faisais
d'éditos on parlait de tout soit de
politique de sport
l'objectif c'est un trait d'union on
parlait à la fois des comores parler des
comoriens du monde
donc moi c'est assez moyen de me tenir
proche de mes racines de me renseigner
de renseigner les autres aussi j'ai
envie de transmettre l'amour que j'ai de
mon pays aujourd'hui ben amir a réuni
son métier des nouvelles technologies et
son engagement il a lancé une web télé
regardez aussi bien par les habitants de
l'archipel que par la diaspora
le nouveau combat de ben amir c'est une
entreprise qu'il vient de créer une
marque d'équipement sportif solidaire
baptisé man parmi ses différents métiers
ben amir est aussi le manager de
l'équipe nationale de foot des comores
alors gratuitement
il va mettre à disposition de la
sélection les maillots qu'il conçoit
mais pour le moment c'est ici à
marseille qu'il fait fabriquer les
équipements d'essai là quand l'équipe de
foot comorienne ce matin sur le port il
a rendez vous avec iph pierre bonny un
de ses fournisseurs dans quelques
semaines l'équipe doit affronter le
maroc pour les qualifications de la
coupe d'afrique des nations convaincre
en rouge
[Musique]
blanc en mourir
rouge et vert les échos mais plutôt de
se demander
il peut sembler surprenant que les
couleurs du maillot d'une équipe
africaine se discute sur le port de
marseille mais pour ben amir cet esprit
d'entreprise au service de son pays et
un devoir pour la communauté comorienne
de la cité phocéenne
ce n'est pas étonnant
d'entrepreneurs de personnes qui
s'engagent pour la je dirais même qu'on
n'est pas assez nombreux au prorata de
la communauté à marseille sont pas assez
nombreux l'entrepreneur qui tue sur un
entrepreneur qui s'est vite au pays je
pense plus à moi aussi a vocation à
développer ce rôle de la diaspora dans
le développement des comores constitue
un grand moteur de la communauté
marseillaise
la société traditionnelle ses valeurs
son organisation se prolonge en france
et organise au sein d'associations le
soutien l'archipel
nous retrouvons mallis à elle participe
aujourd'hui à une réunion associative
avec les notables de la communauté
en fait vous croirait assister à un
conseil des anciens parmi les
participants youssouf sourit le père de
manisa
[Musique]
lors de cette assemblée va se décider
quelles initiatives vont recevoir le
soutien de la communauté
emma lisa est la seule femme à pouvoir
participer à ce niveau de décision
oui effectivement sur la scène femmes
en passe de lui et lui dans les aimants
j'aurais dépassera par rapport aux
hausses de fruits
m même avec ces mots table devant les
notables les porteurs d'initiatives
viennent donc proposer des projets
associatifs qui recevront un soutien
financier
cette jeune femme par exemple veut
lutter contre la délinquance qui gagne
peu à peu les jeunes de la communauté de
libération le conseil est séduit par
l'initiative
ce projet associatif recevra le soutien
des anciens
ce réseau associatif peut aussi décider
des aides qui seront envoyés aux comores
l'aide financière apportée par la
diaspora sera même trois fois supérieure
au budget de l'état comorien
c'est donc à marseille que se décide
certains investissements dans les
infrastructures du pays
l'association des femmes du la manche
sont originaires mais elles peuvent
lever des fonds pour aller
d'adduction d'eau comme à d'autres
associations en confiance et que soient
les enfants des écoles les centres de
santé les publier tec tous les projets
finalement on est
installez les structures en forme sort
essentiellement financée par la dette
aura ici de marseille om depardiou
devant que ce soit dans l'archipel des
comores ou en provence
le réseau associatif se constitue donc
comme un terrain d'expression privilégié
de la solidarité traditionnelle de la
communauté la savine dans les quartiers
nord de marseille entre les cités se
dresse le petit local de la scène
musicale school selon certains habitants
l'association serait même le
conservatoire du hip hop marseillais
le groupe iam et psy 4 de la rime le
chanteur soprano sont tous passés par
l'école fondée il ya vingt ans par soly
m baye et celui continue de s'engager
pour les gamins du quartier qu'ils
viennent non des comores bon genre
jamais les devoirs à faire
[Musique]
sans volant de ce lit et lui aussi l'une
des mémoires de la communauté comorienne
de marseille par le hip hop soul i s'est
détaché de la culture traditionnelle lui
a rejoint un mouvement culturel mondial
cette distance lui permet à sa manière
de faire sortir les comoriens d'une
forme de communautarisme
[Musique]
maya une partie de la communauté qui
s'est réveillée je le dirai et
si consistante que ne pouvant plus
nous cacher raser les murs comme le
faisaient nos parents que cette france
elle est aussi la nôtre pour que les
comoriens de marseille s'éloignent de
leurs traditions et qu'il se décide à
prendre la parole
il a fallu que survienne un événement
tragique la sphère ibrahim ali constitue
le point de départ du réveil de cette
communauté
la naissance d'un mouvement de
revendications et celui mba et était en
première ligne le 21 février 1995 en
pleine campagne pour les élections
présidentielles des militants du front
national viennent coller des affiches au
carrefour des aygalades dans le 15e
arrondissement
ils font la rencontre du groupe de
hip-hop device qui se réunit
régulièrement dans l'association de
solides bases le jeune ibrahima ly 17
ans d'origine comorienne ne sortira pas
vivant de la confrontation
il meurt d'une blessure par balle tirée
dans le dos un garçon calme silencieux
jamais un mot de travers
c'était le grand frère arrivé le 6
cousine
voilà c'est comme ça que je me souvienne
y mourir
après le meurtre d'ibrahim ali le procès
qui a suivi produit un électrochoc sur
la communauté comorienne
mais aussi plus largement sur l'ensemble
de la population composite des
marseillais le militantisme d'extrême
droite
la xénophobie pouvait percuté la
coexistence de ces populations
d'origines diverses et parfois produire
des drames alors régulièrement des élus
marseillais des citoyens des militants
associatifs se regroupent pour
commémorer l'événement lycée
technologique de l'estac dans le 16e
arrondissement 23 ans après les
événements soli mbei seront dans
l'établissement où ibrahim ali suivi sa
scolarité
une plaque en mémoire du jeune homme va
être apposées sur les murs du lycée
la commémoration de cet événement
constitue au delà de la communauté
comorienne un simon pour les populations
de marseille
la diversité des origines qui composent
les habitants de la ville la solidarité
le militantisme contre le racisme
rassemble les différentes communautés au
sein d'un même mouvement de
revendications et de dire oui la
politique future wii de luthier ce
combat c'est aussi celui de samia ghali
la sénatrice des bouches du rhône milite
depuis 20 ans pour la mémoire des jeunes
comoriens certains c'est d'y aller une
blague dans le lycée mais ibrahim ali
méric
elle est emblématique de la ville de
marseille il mérite un lieu emblématique
parce qu'il est mort -notamment et
politiquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les 21 février
je commémore la mort d'ibrahim annick
pas seulement aujourd'hui parce qu'à une
plaque mais tous les 21 février
depuis 1995 et ça fait 23 ans que à
chaque fois je me rappelle à sa mémoire
et geste est de faire rappeler aux
autres la mémoire du brahima dit comme
je n'ai dit c'est un événement
dramatique un événement qui doit plus se
reproduire
un événement qui nous a marqués qui nous
a portés qui nous a choqués cette
mémoire rassemble les élus au delà des
clivages politiques
la sénatrice socialiste samia ghali la
conseillère municipale de droite mallis
aso et lee se retrouvent autour de ce
combat contre la discrimination et plus
de vingt ans après la montée des
populismes dans les démocraties
d'occident redonne une actualité
brûlante à cette mobilisation
on a le sentiment que l'histoire se
répète un peu avec tout ce qui se passe
en europe en france on a le sentiment de
ne pas avoir avancé
on a le sentiment que hier encore plus
de violence il ya un peu plus de racisme
et je veux des plats mais j'espère que
ce type rassemblement ce type de message
va contribuer à faire changer les choses
en tout cas c'est tout l'objectif les
traditions de la société comorienne d'un
côté le militantisme anti raciste de
l'autre à l'image de la communauté venue
des comores jusque dans la cité
phocéenne mali than est enfermé dans
aucun des dogmatismes habituel qui
fracturent la classe politique française
d'ailleurs la conseillère municipale
élue sur une liste de droite à l'époque
ump passé au mouvement dé constructif
d'agir n'a pas de conflit politique
ouvert avec son père boussouf cadre d'un
parti d'extrême gauche des comores le
dimanche sans ma grande et la table or
la famille passe d'ailleurs en ce moment
ma lisa prépare une fête familiale qui
est aussi un des évènements principaux
de la vie sociale des comoriens sont
grands mariages
même si depuis plus de 12 ans elle est
mariée à saïd
elle va bientôt organiser cet événement
qui va la hisser au statut de notable de
la communauté rom a deux souhaits bébé
me convient mais il ya mon beau père
julio silva pour combler la moitié la
planète
c'était ma politique en gros la
politique et le présente même dans votre
vie privée et dans l'assiette
la fibre politique je l'attends mes
parents puisque c'est aux jeux tv des
omanais dans les meetings on m'a menée
dans des réunions associatives
politiques et cetera
donc mes parents ont toujours été
fortement engagé militant et l'uil à des
fonctions éminentes et ça bien entendu
un peu entretenus sur moi donc oui j'ai
grandi au biberon là la politique
lorsque youssouf swahili observe le
parcours de sa fille ses études au sein
des grandes écoles
son militantisme au sein du parti
gaulliste puis de centre droit sa
carrière d'élu de la république
le militant communiste comoriens ne peut
pas caché sa fierté ou mal ils devaient
fait des larmes
en l'envoyant tenir un discours avec une
éloquence leader est surprenante puisque
à une formation des nappes et les nappes
comme l'ont été hollande et les autres
hélas le profil de tout ce qui indique
juste prix son parcours exemplaire et
son mandat municipal fond de ma lisa le
porte-voix de toute une communauté
jusque là invisible dans la vie
politique marseillaise
mon engagement politique
à marseille les partis d'un constat
c'est que tout d'abord on a les
représentants élus dans un territoire
n'était pas le reflet de la population
ce territoire donc on a voulu aussi
porté la voix la diversité au sens de la
politique locale et
on s'est dit aussi qu'on pouvait
apporter notre pierre à l'édifice
participer à la vie de la cité ne pas
être simplement des citoyens silencieux
mais citoyen qui porte si une voix qui
apportent leur contribution et qui ont
les mêmes compétences que les sommes
prévues à plus de 7000 kilomètres de
leur archipel la famille sourit comme de
nombreux comoriens de marseille
s'impliquent pour bâtir un tissu
associatif très actif
un espace qui leur permet de vivre
pleinement leur culture tout en tissant
un lien fort avec la république
un défi qu'il relève jour après jour
pour sortir la communauté comorienne de
l'anonymat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public sénat avec le soutien de mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires vous a
présenté c'est vous la france